okay so we look at the first two Pataki
and variations in fair amount of detail
over the years I've seen this done in a
number of different ways slight in ways
by different teachers or same as if you
play the same feature different time so
problem chase down the length exclusion
I'm sort of stuck with a version how how
I see the exercise working okay so if
there's any sort of minor details don't
worry too much about laughs look at
trial occur while I'm trying to do with
the exercise and the bigger picture
inserted in our earlier video that
Aikido keeps other martial up positive
that is how you move and when you make a
step with weapons or without the weapons
it's not like you just walk you you're
moving in that specific way that means
you're moving in powerful way and then
reserving some of that power at the end
of the movement if you can walk in
you're throwing lots of power light and
[Music]
low energy boom so eventually when you
move which is become natural so you get
a powerful movement all the way you get
a stable posture and it's just there all
the time
it's kind of free yeah it is no low
metabolic cost if you like when you use
strengths just there all the time so it
makes you improvements much more
powerful I don't do this you generally
have to start slowly and build up on the
attacking side the first movement is the
thrust forward and with the side now on
here needs to cover a lot of distance
now this is a really good example how
the hips need to move to get your whole
body poop if I just try to step all the
forward the mode powering on I'm doing
here I need to get my feet down
unloading on front leg perfectly load
I've been set here what's on here
literally waiting on transfer weight
more lightly ready for the next move
okay three levels of before wheel with
its side so slowly stopping it with kind
of stopping and starting
so he brings you wait I knew he moved
I'm not going to show you that one we
just couldn't do second languages moving
together and is pausing to each move
thirdly to pk first one is it so people
the starting point we've actually quite
Hardy or changes the change the head
forward slightly so it's better do do
this the second level third popping also
I like to have a bill push to the on the
defender so they kind of lose is that
and if you do that firstly then kind of
leash to take the whole thing is a big
fat it now from here he he literally
lift when I get to clear under the
thrust on the ear now we look like the
him is that my sword is come across line
and like this he'll be able to break it
a fact which I break until now kind of
an illusion subway though like I do I
keep the point of my saw on the line
here not pitted okay the other thing see
a lot is about they favor as he raises
but become in reaches in and they come
back they stand up they then take this
all the way all that it's like touching
them with the sole that's not really
losing oh you know when I'm going down
will go deep deep I think it's
the other side somewhere go for shallow
that's fine I think I choose to go in
okay
I've lived in it here so that's my
choice to go here appear now captain
pouty like trusty down his leg now I'm
gonna turn and cut now he has enough
time to do a full car which do in the
form of exercise so I'd like to weigh
from the list which is a bit kind of P
just all he does the above
cut so we go through the vast pastimes
and turn from here
now go keep contact how is strike here
it is you put the fishing copy okay a
couple things before we go further
right so the starting point of the keep
walking touches is here now
I don't think exercise is about really
starting here it's kind of healthy
convenient start position some of the
some moves a bit unrealistic as a
starting point on a year in the middle
of something and this is like a snapshot
of the action this whole point through
that's how I seem to give you the cube
attention okay the pillar cut is big
compute easily what's going on so these
comes round destroyed food stuff here
it's Philly so he thought about of why
yeah why might be can we just keep going
if you come around the other side
Charlie and then feeling all along with
like you do the menial East last club is
putting time and there okay deflate the
sword and finishes it okay
if you do time you end up showing up you
feel like coming down so by changing the
distance
slimey's get full cut okay the cubic
taxis are modified swords that is no
kind of slicing with a full belt
developing your Center and your power
okay so look at the cube that hey half
again all in each move please finish boo
okay the 230 set of variations
this one has 240 variations to came
variation and point of them is to show
that the Kin and the empty handed
basically the same okay the tacky side
plays the same and the defending side of
the variation
hey case variation Hey but money very a
hang so take under the sword flip a few
clothes for you
go down run back into me yes up this is
after the foot move now from there you
could cut my head it was round tap okay
so in the mobile fibonacci I've got a
tall fat back cover this line okay so
now it's always got the side first
variation and you can make sound I
control it
go do it slowly so any come round I
would bring this down in time with him
tips draw that there but I keep cutting
down with his cup controlling it with me
from coming it slightly I'm off the line
of the cup okay
careful where the typical game okay so
first can duration for the first body
variation here okay so under they're
essentially the same feeling back
slightly and get more lift under it okay
that's where that's going under there if
you feel roughly the same we do a third
cake expert forty sympathetic my side is
be held down pit now I'll listen to the
throat
[Music]
you can variation hey think so I control
beyond these rhetorical a second fully
variation hi ah I cut down top of the
third hole of the dealer 1 okay second
variation and happens at the end of the
hip fatty
Lord Ganpati fish comes without
footprint variations I pick up feed on
and he comes it here okay bully
variations feels similar as you come
this going to cut here I go off the link
up between these is and rotates grabs or
lift you up using my elbow on the heel
oh right okay plus the first few catchy
and variation I'll remember point of the
sole exercises not become a sort of a
net such to learn the body movements and
to develop Perrineau postures in
structure lots of opportunities in the
queue attach each delay we know where to
look
so the way to train them is yes steadily
thinner and hopefully okay
[Applause]
[Music]